welcome everyone i'm susie valdez and i
will be your moderator for today's event
thank you for joining us for this
presentation titled adding
value to food and agricultural waste
immediate and longer term applications
it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker today dr vincent
balloon director of the research center
at the university of adelaide
adelaide glycomics research consortium
for agriculture
project development and fight food waste
cooperative research center for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the tab
at the top of your screen if you have
any questions that arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
and a box
our speaker will address your questions
following his
presentation please join me now in
welcoming dr vincent
balon i will now turn the presentation
over to him
welcome sir
so welcome to my presentation first i
would like to thank
dr david bradley and the agilent team
for inviting me
to present some of our activities
here in adelaide but also in my other
lab in sweden at the royal institute of
technology
so my presentation will focus on some
key
examples where we are using
biomolecules for specific applications
and the research
that leads to these applications
but before
the scientific details i thought i
should introduce myself briefly i'm a
biochemist by training
and i have been running research
programs on
carbohydrates from plants algae or my
seeds and fungi
for about 30 years now we are very
strong in
enzymology carbohydrate enzymology
and applications derived from
carbohydrates
but also solving the structure and the
properties
of complex polysaccharides
and the applications are in a whole
range of sectors biomaterials i will
illustrate
some of this in my presentation but also
by your energy the biomass can be
fermented in particular the
carbohydrates into
ethanol and food sustainability i will
not discuss this in my presentation but
we are targeting
cell wall biosynthesis in pathogenic
microorganisms for disease control
and biorefinery is the exploitation of
biomolecules again from the biomass
through sequential extractions of
compounds
and the utilization for a number of
applications and a lot of what we do
especially in my other lab in sweden
is derived from forest products in
particular
cellulose the research centers i'm
leading at the moment are the
agricultural product development
research consortium this is a grant
funded by the
south australian state government
focusing
on converting agricultural waste into
products with a higher value
i'm also the research director of the
fight food waste
crc cooperative research center dealing
also
with food waste but across the entire
uh value chain not only um
around um material that doesn't leave
the farm which is the focus
of the agricultural product development
research consortium
and for both these initiatives other
glycomics
is our partner laboratory with agilent
uh
technologies plays a key role in
analytical work
for the different biomolecules we're
analyzing
look this is the situation in australia
about the cost of agricultural waste
in australia it is it is estimated to
represent around 20 billion
australian dollar per annum across the
entire value chain
and 20 percent of this uh of the primary
horticult production is lost pre-farm
gate
which represents uh close to 1.7 1.8
billion loss per annum but what is
probably
most worrying is the curves that we see
on this slide since the mid 1990s the
population in australia has increased
by around 30 percent and you can see
what happens with the amount of waste we
generate
it follows a much faster rate and this
is obviously unsustainable so in our
research programs we are trying to
address these issues by converting the
waste
into products with a higher value making
something useful
food waste is a big problem which is not
specific
to the western countries and the
so-called developing countries also
suffer from these issues and in
everywhere in the world basically
there is always a fraction of the
population
that suffers from malnutrition and this
again applies also in our so-called
modern societies
if you take a cauliflower this example
about only 15
of the cauliflower is actually eaten
and you can see that most of the rest is
ever left in the field
or it's not edible or it's simply wasted
by the consumer
so we are trying to do something useful
uh with the basically 85 percent
uh that is not used uh that is not eaten
waste is used for three main
applications either
it is uh burnt to produce energy
and even the most efficient systems
produce energy but this is still a low
value
product i would say the biomass can also
be composted or used for
feed for animals these different streams
generate low value zero to ten dollars a
ton if we're talking about feed for
animals for instance
and we think we can do much better
this is one of the activities of the crc
which is about exploiting uh the waste
in many different areas but also trying
to reduce the waste
and change consumer behavior as well so
we have three programs
in the crc the reduce program which is
focusing
as the name infers on reducing food
waste
and this can be at different levels for
example just simply optimizing
packaging or ways to preserve food
during packaging and transport is a way
to reduce
the food waste the second program in
which my activities are more
specifically involved is the transform
program
where we are converting the biomass
into a whole range of products um
so this involves biorefinery
bioconversion
and then product development as well and
the third program called
engage is more about educating the
future industry
leaders r d leader so we have a program
specifically dedicated to the training
of phd students in the food waste area
in the broad context
but also trying to educate
the end user the consumer to avoid
and manage the food waste and as you can
see on the top of the slide
there are estimations on where the
food is wasted across the entire value
chain and we are trying to act
at every one of these different points
represented
at the top here uh to reduce uh
at least by 50 percent of food waste uh
in the next 10 years so it's an
ambitious program
but we're hoping to achieve at least
some significant
impact for society in that space
that i mentioned earlier uh at the
beginning of the presentation is the
state government grant called research
consortium program for agricultural
product development
so this is focusing on south australian
biomass
but we have multiple partners across the
country but
also international partners as well and
without going into
the details uh the program one is about
understanding the structure
of complex carbohydrates and bioactives
that we found in agricultural crops
program two is about assessing their
properties
um either biological activity and we're
talking for instance about anti-fungal
properties anti-inflammatory properties
antioxidant properties anti-cancer
properties
but also the structural properties of
carbohydrates like cellulose and starch
and caitin from mushrooms and program 3
is really about
developing products from these different
molecules from the waste
and scaling up the production of some of
the molecules
and also exploiting them commercially
eventually what we are trying to do is
to
use as close to 100 of the waste as
possible
so that we do not generate waste from
the waste
if i can say by doing sequential
extractions of the molecules
and minimizing the residue that we will
have at the end
there is no point uh targeting a
molecule that is
of super high value i can say but that
is present only at one to two percent in
the biomass
because if we do that we will still have
uh 95 98 percent of waste so we are
trying to
basically have an integrated sequential
process
that will extract a whole range of
compounds
sequentially and derive them into
products with a higher value
and again here adelaide glycomics is
playing a key role
in uh providing analytical support uh
through our partner laboratory with with
with agilent
to this different for the rest of my
presentation i decided to take some
examples
uh i could go on for quite a while but i
picked a few
examples to illustrate what we are doing
more concretely
so the first polymer we're interested in
is cellulose cellulose is present in
every single plant at different levels
depending on the type of crop
considerate but also the type of
issue so it varies from about 20 percent
to up to 80 percent depending
again on the type of tissues and
therefore it can be
used uh as a valuable product from
basically any type
of waste and this is what we had
first of all we can prepare cellulose in
different forms
in a cellulose nanofibrils abbreviated
by cnf here
cellulose nanocrystals abbreviated by
cnc
and i will provide examples uh uh in a
minute
about how to use cnf and cncs for
applications
um another form of cellulose that does
not come from plants is bacterial
cellulose
it is however extremely expensive to
produce
at the moment and it would be even if it
would become commercially
um viable it would still be for a niche
market
because it's also difficult to use on a
large scale
but the highest source of cellulose is
of course wood
the problem with wood cellulose is that
it's heavily lignified which means that
it needs to be
processed which is expensive and also
generates
a lot of solvent
issues that need to be managed but
cellulose as
summarized on this slide can be used for
many uh different applications
and i'm going to give you a little bit
more insight into that
next slides so if you would pull out
from your shirt your cotton shirt
a fiber uh it would look uh
like like it is represented at the top
of the slide
in other words it's a highly aggregated
network of cellulose microfibrils
and this network can be used obviously
for textile and paper
but we can do more useful things if we
dissociate this network
and there are two ways two main ways to
doing that
one is through mechanical shearing the
other one is by combining mechanical
shearing with enzymatic hydrolysis
and when you do that you basically
dissociate the sub elements
of this macro fibrils into
microfibrillated cellulose
and this microfibrillated cellulose can
be visualized with different forms of
microscopy
and it can be converted for instance in
hydrogels
that can be used for cosmetics
applications for instance
and other human applications so it's a
quite a straightforward
process if you
would make a nanopaper by simply drying
the microfiber related cellulose you can
derive
the cellulose in a transparent film that
is bendable
and that can also be modified
on the surface to make it for instance
water repellent
and design transparent self-cleaning
surfaces
the reason why this material is
transparent compared to normal
paper is because it consists of
microfibrillated cellulose and as you
can see
on this slide the pores of the nanopaper
compared to a classical
piece of paper are very small which
means that the light
does not diffuse as much as in a normal
paper
which creates opacity in the normal
paper
whereas the nano paper is instead
transparent
because it doesn't diffuse the light as
much as
this microfiber related cellulose can
also be
freeze dried to generate super tough
foams the material you see on this slide
consists only of 30
solid material the rest is air and it's
as light as polystyrene so it can be
used potentially for
packaging as an insulating material
because it's porous
but also as a carrier for pharmaceutical
and biomedical applications for instance
so it's super light
and super tough and it can be converted
into a whole range of
applications through a very simple
process again
dissociating the fibers and freeze
drying them
to generate another thing we can do
with cellulose is to hydrolyze it so
this is
how cellulose looks like if you extract
it from a primary cell wall from a plant
in a native form but if you treat it
with a strong acid
you will hydrolyze the least crystalline
parts of the cellulose microfibrils and
end up with what we call cellulose
whiskers
because they are similar in their
aspects as cat whiskers this is where
the name
comes from so these are basically uh the
most crystalline parts of the celosic
microfibrils
and they are quite homogeneous inside
they are in the range of 2 to 300
nanometers
so what can we do with this nano crystal
well we can suspend them uh in a liquid
and depending on the concentration of
the
nano crystals we can potentially
generate
or really generate i should say um what
is called a carol pneumatic phase
or if you like it's a liquid crystalline
phase and this is what is represented at
the bottom of the tube
if the sample is more diluted as
represented at the top of the tube
you end up with an isotropic suspension
where the nano crystals have a random
orientation
but as you concentrate the suspension
again represented at the bottom of the
tube a liquid crystalline phase
forms spontaneously so if we look at
what's happening in the bottom of the
bottom of the tube to the top you can
see that on each plane
the cellulose nano crystals which are
represented by these
small black lines slightly change
orientation by your small angle and as
you keep going up
along the tube the angle changes from
one plane to another
and this is a spontaneous process if you
will dry this material
you end up with the films that are
represented on the right hand side
that are irredesent in other words they
interfere with the transport of the
light through the material
or in other words the color changes the
color of the material changes depending
on the incidence of the light
on the material
by nature it's the same process as used
by
uh some insects uh there
there are no pigments in fact involved
here at all
it's just uh nanostructures in case of
the insects it's nanostructures made of
chitin
that provide iridescence so in this
particular case we have used cellulose
and if the nanocrystals are combined
with salt
we can make colored films
that again change color depending on the
incidence of light
examples of applications are in the
paints
for instance so you could have a paint
for your car made of this material
that changes color slightly depending on
the
incidence of the light from the sun on
the paint of your car and there are many
other potential
applications of the
in the other example i said at the
beginning we are quite strong in
carbohydrate and semology i will show
you a couple of examples
of what we can do with enzymes that act
on carbohydrate polymers
so here we have uh used an enzyme
that acts on alginates this is a
carbohydrates that is found in
seaweeds and it consists of manuronic
acid represented here in pink and
gularonic acid represented in blue
the enzyme we have isolated uh acts
uh faster on polymanuronic acid
stretches
um than it does on polyglonic acid
stretches so if you incubate
algae night from let's say brown seaweed
in the presence of this enzyme
it will release an unsaturated
monosaccharide
and this unsaturated monosaccharide is
spontaneously converted it's a
spontaneous reaction
into a molecule that we call deh for
deoxy
erythro exosulos uronic acid
and this molecule can be used as a
precursor for bioplastics but also
potentially
as a whitening agent for skin
formulations which has a lot of interest
in some parts of the world so
express this enzyme and characterize it
biochemically we have shown
that indeed it interacts more favorably
with stretches of manuronic acid than
guleronic acids
and we have determined its ph optimal ph
optimal temperature and it's actually
active
on a quite a large range of ph and
temperature which makes it very useful
potentially for industrial
so when we use the enzyme on
alginates it degrades preferentially
again the polymanuronic acid stretches
to generate dh
and this slide demonstrates that we are
able to produce dh
uh in a rigorously pure form and
the edge is actually which makes it uh
very easy to purify we have demonstrated
that the process can be scaled up this
is what is represented on this slide
so when we add the enzyme which is
abbreviated here by tc
arg1 to alginate in water
we can then simply incubate the enzyme
with the algae nite
it will release the dh molecule
which is soluble in ethanol so by simply
adding 95
ethanol we simply solubilize in one step
the deh molecule
and the rest remains insoluble
and the rest that is insoluble is the
part of the alginate
on which the enzyme has not acted and
this part of the alginate
is rich in guleronic acid remember the
enzyme doesn't act very well on urinic
acid
and this allows us to solubilize the dh
in ethanol
while retaining in an insoluble form a
gularonic acid-rich
alginate residue the dh can be used as i
said before as a precursor for
bioplastic but also
in skin whitening formulations
whereas guleronic acid as a polymer has
been shown to have
a biological activity anti-fungal
activity
and it is uh used at the moment in
clinical trials for the treatment of
respiratory diseases
against aspergillus so it has antifungal
properties but also other biological
activities
it can be used for the prevention of the
formation of biofilms for instance
a lot of potential applications the
system is fully scalable we have
produced here in a 50 milliliter
reaction
about 2 grams of ph and the rest
is alginate a third example
is about again the use of another enzyme
which belongs to the lytic
polysaccharide monooxygenase family
we have isolated this enzyme from a
fungal pathogen of rice visayan fuji
choroid
and we have expressed this enzyme
recombinantly
and purified it to homogeneity and this
is what this slide
illustrates here we have first expressed
it uh with the signal
sequence peptide uh that's the plb
sequence which allows the enzyme to be
secreted
in the culture medium and the
[Music]
signal peptide is removed by biopeptides
from from the bacterial strains
in which we have expressed it so once we
have purified
we were able to use it to modify chitin
for instance
so what this enzyme does is that it
breaks down
the chitin chain by creating
a carboxylic function at the reducing
ends
of the sugars that are modified and it
acts specifically
on carbon 1 on the of the sugar residues
what the enzyme does though is that it
does not completely degrade cartine
which is a big advantage here
because it can be used for surface
modification
only in other words we do not lose uh
the crystalline part of the chitin
so we can keep chitin fibers intact
while introducing carboxylic functions
at the surface of the chitin
which can then be used to encore
a whole range of molecules to
functionalize the surface of the chitin
in these examples we have used that you
can see in the box at the bottom of the
slide
fluorescein fitc fluorescein
isothiocyanate as
a modifying agent and also a small
peptide that consists of glycine
alanine and leucine as an example
of what can be done is represented here
so on the left hand side on panel a
you can see at the top the modification
of chitin which has become fluorescence
with fitc
and um that's panel a1
anal a2 is the same picture of the
commercial chitin
but in the bright field observation
under the optical microscope
finals three and four are just the
control without
the treatment with the enzyme so you can
see that the reaction is highly specific
on panel b we have
modified lobster shells directly with
the chitin or fragment of a lobster
shell
so panel one is the control and two and
three
are the fluorescently modified lobster
shells which are rich in chitin so the
enzymes
working even on solid materials so this
is
heterogeneous catalysis if you like it's
a very efficient
enzyme on the right hand side the mass
spectra
reflects also the capacity to modify
oligosaccharides with the same reaction
and modify them with peptides and this
can be used to make bioactive
oligosaccharides functionalized with
peptides for instance so the reaction is
very versatile we use a whole range of
molecules and this is summarized here
on this slide where again chitin is
first functionalized
with the enzyme the lpmo
to introduce carboxylic functions at the
surface
of the material followed then by the
grafting of a whole range of
compounds for functionalization and you
can see here a number of
specific applications
in this presentation which is about the
generation of uv protective materials
what we have done here is to exploit
small molecules called microsporines and
microsparine like amino acids
these molecules absorb uv-a
and uvb radiations and they are normally
produced by
different organisms algae in particular
but also some
cyanobacteria and the fish
that thrive in tropical waters
like the great barrier reef in in in
australia for instance
acquire these microsporines by eating
algae
and it's a way for them to protect
themselves against the
negative impact of the uv lights so what
we have done
in in this was to exploit these
microsporines to generate uv protective
materials so there are two main types of
microsporines
which are derivatives of cyclohexamine
and cyclohexenone
and they're basically amino acid
derivatives
of these core structures what is
important on this slide is the values of
the epsilon that you have at the bottom
these values reflect the molar
absorption coefficient of these
molecules
and it shows how powerful they are in
absorbing
uh ultraviolet ray radiations these
values are twice as high as what you
need
to claim that you have an efficient
sunscreen
product to be put on the market so
extremely
high capacity to absorb uv radiation so
we have simply
to make a conjugate uh with chitosan so
the molecules have carboxylic functions
and chitosan is a they are saturated
form of
chitin which carries three amino groups
so by a simple
amidation reaction we can produce
a stable conjugate a covalent conjugate
that combines the properties of the
chitosan with the uv absorbing
properties
of the microsporin
and the conjugate can be turned into a
very thin film
of about 30 micrometer thick the film is
completely transparent
and it blocks uh completely uva and uvb
radiation so unique properties here are
from this film
uh what is represented here is a
modification of the kitazan
by only a three percent of micros
increase uh the concentration to ten
percent of microsporines
uh you can see that the uv radiations
are completely blocked
whereas the transmittance in the visible
light
remains close to 100 in other words the
films remain completely transparent
while blocking completely uva and uvb
radiations
stable so here we have irradiated the
films
to an amount of uv
radiations that is equivalent to the
number of sun
to the amount of sun you get over a
period of nearly 10 years in queensland
and 15 years in victoria
and south australia and what this shows
is that
the film is stable under these high
uv radiation conditions in other words
it could be used as a coating material
for instance for outdoor furniture
and still be stable after 10 years in
queensland
and 15 years in south australia
and victoria so lots of potential
thermal resistance so if you cook it at
uh
close to 100 degrees uh for up to 12
hours
its absorption capacity does not change
and this applies to the different
microsporines we have tested so the
m glee uh the shinrin and the p334
are all stable after a conjugation to
kitozen
the control abbreviated here by cs uh
is the kaitozan itself that has not been
modified so you can see that the
absorption spectra
of the three conjugates we have made
with the three microsporines
uh are thermal resistant
biocompatible here we have grown skin
cells on the films and we have used the
live dead assay
to check the viability of the cells
in what happens here is that the cells
turn
red when they are dead and
in fact when they are alive they they
turn green
when the cells are alive they are able
to metabolize the fluorescent dye
that we have used which is normally red
and convert it into a
green fluorescent uh dye
if the cells are dead they are not able
to metabolize the dye
which remains red and therefore the red
the cells that are dead
are visible in in red color in other
words and in summary here you can see
that
we have basically no cell death
which means that the cells can grow
happily on this type of material which
shows their biocompatibility
and direct potential application for
in a human tissues so a lot of
versatility
shows that the cells stick very well to
the film
on the left it's the kaitozan that has
not been modified
on the right is the kaitos are modified
with the
glycine microsporine and you can see
that the cells
spread very well on the material so they
are highly biocompatible and they can be
used for
skin care products and protect the skin
against the impact of uv radiation so
this has been now
patented and we are developing it as a
commercial product
not only for skin care products but
also for coating materials outdoor
furniture
uh glasses outdoor textiles and
and many more materials this is the end
of my
presentation i hope you have enjoyed the
types of applications we can generate
these are only a few
examples i could continue for
quite a while and i will be happy
then to take questions and here i'm also
thanking of course the people that have
contributed to the work
especially from my lab in sweden
uh the names of the contributors are
highlighted
in green and thank you for your
attention and i hope you enjoyed this
presentation
thank you dr balloon for that
outstanding presentation
and we will now move to the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q and a
box
so we'll give them a couple seconds to
get their questions in
would you like to add any comments to
our audience right now dr balloon or
waiting for some questions
yeah a question that i'm very often
asked you know this
is going to uh to come is uh how far you
know we are from commercialization
um it depends on the products i would
say
um in most instances we still
need to upscale the production of some
of these so for instance for the uv
protective materials
uh we are dependent on obtaining
microsporines on a larger scale
a way to do that is through a metabolic
engineering so reconstructing the
pathway
biosynthetic pathways in organisms we
can grow easily like
bacteria or yeast to produce the
molecules in large amounts but basically
we have made formulations that
work for skin care products for instance
other compounds that are dependent on
the use of enzymes
require again large scale production of
enzymes in fermenters
which can be done of course these
enzymes are easy to express we have
demonstrated that
for the for the nanocellulose it's
already a commercial product
and it can be used in very many
different applications there's a
manual growth rate compound annual
growth rate
predicted to be of around 30 percent for
the next
uh five to ten years for nanocellulose
and most of it is done
uh it's already produced industrially
and most of it comes from
from wood and it can go you know i gave
these examples here but it can go also
in composite materials to make um
reinforced materials for car panels or
even for a aeroplane panels
making materials super light but strong
at the same time
and so some of these products could go
on the market you know in the near
future they're all at different stages
and the limitations are always you know
upscaling
and also of course looking at the market
demand
and the cost of production
dr balloon i want to thank you for your
presentation today and your important
research
and i want to thank our audience members
and remind them that there are still
opportunities to ask questions questions
that were submitted but not answered
today by our speaker will be addressed
via email
and this presentation will be available
on demand viewing through september
2021 please share it with your colleague
who might have been
interested in this topic thank you again
for your participation
and i hope you will enjoy and join me
for the next presenter
georgia gonzalez thank you again dr
balloon
and if you're not thank you virtual
studio take care
be safe until next time everyone bye-bye
thank you bye-bye